foreign
good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight on Tuesday two days ago
Twitter slapped a warning label on all
tweets from National Public Radio going
forward NPR will be identified for users
of Elon Musk social media site as quote
State Affiliated media that is the same
category as Russia today or China's
Central television it means that NPR is
not that different from the Tehran times
with the exception of course being less
accurate and more anti-American so that
happened on Tuesday why are we telling
you about it with all the momentous
changes underway around the world why
would we open a show with a story about
Twitter recategorizing NPR estate media
well because it's true that's the reason
finally thankfully somebody in Authority
has told the truth about something and
that is thrilling to see on its own
terms in a world defined by lies from
our leaders this seemed like a rare sign
of Hope and progress
telling the truth is the most
revolutionary Act of all far more than
taking up arms and yet you rarely see it
human beings created language in order
to describe the world around them more
precisely than they could with say
grunting or sign language but
unfortunately have been subverting our
own creation ever since but not tonight
by calling National Public Radio what it
is Elon Musk has used English as it was
intended to be used in order to tell the
truth
of course NPR is State media Have you
listened to it it is all the Hallmarks
repetitive dishonesty authoritarian
politics unwavering Devotion to the
party in charge
of course that could describe virtually
all media in this country the difference
is the state actually pays for NPR NPR
was created more than 50 years ago by a
law signed by Democrat Lyndon Johnson it
was called the public broadcasting act
and from its very first day NPR was
wholly dependent on tax dollars in order
to exist and it still is
Federal funding is essential to NPR
explains NPR's own website
so there's no factual debate about that
fact but there is a great deal of lying
about it every year NPR lobbyists head
to Capitol Hill to demand more tax
dollars democracy can't exist without us
they Screech will simultaneously at the
very same time telling you at high
volume that NPR takes virtually no tax
money
so we don't need Federal subsidies don't
even want them really but you have to
increase them
that is NPR's line and has been for
decades under the political leadership
of both parties
and it's essentially unchallenged by
anyone it just
stays Wars and recessions come and go
but NPR funding remains
but after more than half a century it is
very clear that there is nothing public
about national public radio NPR is the
radio station of permanent Washington
that's who pays for it that's who
benefits from it by adding three simple
words to NPR's tweets Elon Musk exposed
that forever to the world such is the
power of Truth it exposes and of course
it infuriates those who are exposed so
NPR howled an outraged but with its
signature purse-lipped fussiness
here's a direct quote from a piece on
NPR's website which really does belong
in the museum of uptight liberalism
quote
NPR officials have asked Twitter to
remove the label they initially assumed
it was applied by mistake NPR
spokesperson Isabel Lara said we were
not warned it happened quite Suddenly
Last Night Laura said
in response to an NPR email for the
story seeking comment and requesting
details about what in particular might
have led to the new designation
Twitter's press account Auto replied
with a poop emoji
what's just so perfect you couldn't
improve it hey Twitter stop calling us
what we are
okay NPR here's a scat cartoon
so you can forget the Rockets and the
electric cars Elon Musk is a hero for
this alone
but NPR wasn't finished it still had
fight
national public radio was so angry so
enraged to be called State media that
its supporters Enlisted the help of the
regime's top spokeswoman to claim
otherwise stop calling it propaganda
said the propagandist
again it's an irony free zone and just
too great watch this
there's no doubt of the independence of
NPR's journalists and it has been if
you've ever been on the receiving end of
their of their questions that you know
this you know that they have their
independence in journalism NPR
journalists work digitally to hold
public officials accountable and inform
the American people the hard-hitting
independence nature of their coverage
speaks uh speaks for itself and so I'll
leave it there
that is so Baghdad Bob it's unbelievable
here she is reading a press release for
NPR that tells us they're famous for
hard-hitting Independence which speaks
for itself
really
how many tough questions have they asked
you Karina Jean-Pierre
not a single one they're fluffing her
every day she's so smart
and so she pays them back hard-hitting
Independence this is the same radio
station that in the final days of the
last presidential campaign took a look
at the biggest political story in years
the New York Post story on Hunter
Biden's laptop and then ignored it
completely and not only ignored it
completely but because they are fussy
and self-righteous to their very core
they bragged about how they were
ignoring it completely we don't want to
waste our time on stories that are not
really stories said NPR's managing
editor Terence Samuel
and we don't want to waste listeners and
readers time on stories that are just
pure distractions
all right
potential campaign we find out the
Democratic candidate has been taking
money from a foreign adversary but
that's just a distraction
so whatever happened to Terence Samuel
what did he get in return for helping
Joe Biden become president at the state
Affiliated media Network he serves well
Terence Samuel has since been promoted
to NPR's executive editor but he still
has time to spare because it's not that
hard to put morning sedition on the air
so you know what he does in his spare
time Terence Samuel hosts seminars on
we're quoting disinformation and
democracy at something called American
University
I know we're not making any of this up
nor are we fabricating NPR's report from
just last month that informed us male
athletes have no inherent performance
advantages over female athletes none at
all that is a fact ladies and gentlemen
men and women are physically the same
size they have the same muscle mass
there is no difference whatsoever in
their bone structure we checked with
experts
so as you know NPR is famous for its
widely respected science coverage but
that's not the only reason that NPR is
now the go-to news source for unhappy
female attorneys over 50. no there's
more to it than that they're the
lifestyle pieces the features as they
used to say in the newspaper business
here's a piece for example on how one
African-American Barbie doll ahead of
its time in the toy industry changed the
life of a latinx girl forever
I remember this one Christmas
my cousin's father gifted us all Barbies
and when everyone was unwrapping you
know the excitement the papers
and I opened up the Barbie and my Barbie
was black
you know and everyone kind of like
looked at my Barbie and I looked at
their Barbies and I could kind of like
identify to their Barbies too and I
wasn't this kind of like as melanated as
this Barbie and I was like oh my gosh I
am different
unhappy middle-aged ladies talking about
themselves the narcissism piped directly
into your Audi
that's NPR you got to say they know
their audience they don't really serve
Their audience they put their audience
on the air so it's kind of a continuous
loop the snake eating its own tail so
you probably shouldn't be too surprised
that with an audience like it's
desperately unhappy Barren personal life
audience that NPR is all in on the
question of romance novels watch
I'm like really big in the Sci-Fi ones
one of the books was a gay couple and
one of them was a kraken and I didn't
want that to unlock something in me
unfortunately it did before I knew it
was happening Cyrus was carrying me the
muscular lengths of his tentacles
supporting our combined weight and
shuffling us towards the cell without
breaking our kiss I knew he was strong
but I didn't think he was that strong
you like that Roland he asked as his
tentacle slam the door to the shower
stall open and we stumbled inside
[Music]
also it's tentacle porn okay yeah I mean
technically it is tentacle porn which is
his own sub-genre and we're not going to
pollute your mind by telling you any
more about it than that but what it
really is is narcissism because here you
have an upper income Oberlin graduate
talking about what would he be talking
about well himself of course because
that's what NPR listeners want to hear
about themselves and that's the real
journalism the hard-hitting independent
journalism Korean Jean-Pierre was
touting from the White House briefing
room and NPR didn't just start doing it
after they got Joe Biden elected they've
been doing it for Generations
their health coverage in particular
stands out any news organization can run
a piece on how to be more healthy
but only NPR dared to affirm the snack
habits of its listeners by telling you
yeah go ahead and be fat here's an
anti-diet diet dietitian
so diet culture is this overarching
system of beliefs and values it's really
endemic to Western culture at this point
in history
Christy Harrison is an anti-diet
registered dietitian with a master's in
public health
we've been trying to get Christy
Harrison the anti-diet diet dietitian on
our show for years now but we're not NPR
so no luck so far but if you're looking
for coverage of lgbtqia
Z Plus issues well you've come to the
right place because it's not just the
conventional stuff gay marriage or trans
issues they've taken it to another level
as befits a Cutting Edge totally
Independent News Channel like National
Public Radio here they are reporting on
trans dinosaur experts
many people who are queer whether they
are trans or some other form of
genderqueer or whatever it is we love
dinosaurs along with being a dinosaur
expert Riley is herself transgender and
according to Riley there is a whole
community of genderqueer dinosaur
enthusiasts online
we had no idea so we checked it out sure
enough they're there we found dozens of
paleo artists online that identify as
queer type dinosaur into the LGBT
subreddit hundreds of results with pride
dinos rainbow dinos Dino moms Dino dads
and a lot of puns like Ally Soros trans
ceratops
trans serotopes transasaurus Rex now a
lot of people say if the topic of NPR
comes up in conversation yeah I'm all
for national public radio and I'm happy
to work an extra day a year to pay for
it
but I'm not a trans dinosaur
I'm not
so what's in it for me is a non-trans
dinosaur that seems a little niche and
that's a common misperception about
national public radio as long as you're
talking about yourself and doing so in a
self-satisfied completely out of touch
way
NPR's station for you in other words
they're interested in all forms of
diversity back in 2021 NPR discovered a
trendy new television show why they like
it well here's why
well Kumari what TV show were you
binging this year I was watching we are
lady Parts it's a musical comedy about a
punk band in London that is made up of
all Muslim women
what are you watching that's the
hard-hitting news coverage that makes
the difference between democracy and
tyranny what are you watching
self-satisfied fussy people with nose
piercings talking about what they're
watching inside their tiny little
apartments in Brooklyn well I'm watching
a musical in all Muslim Trends musical a
punk band
it's great
so that's NPR in 2023 and the truth is
NPR's always been kind of awful kind of
unbearable kind of cringy as they say
but now
you can't even listen to it because the
people who work there are deranged
they're ideologues and ideologues of
course in the end go crazy and start
attacking each other the revolution
inevitably eats its own and we're seeing
that on display now and frankly kind of
enjoying it so after NPR laid off 10
percent of its staff recently one NPR
show called louder than a riot
louder than a riot
they love riots in FBR tweeted this and
we're quoting
the hardest part is that our sin sdn if
you're not Hungarian you probably know
what that means we certainly don't or as
zien is about Ms genwar queer trans
black women face in hip-hop yet within
NPR the majority impacted in these
layoffs were queer POC staff and
programs
in other words racist
by the way Miss genuar in case you
aren't up on your NPR speaker something
to do with bigotry against women who are
black not that NPR bothers to Define any
of those terms anyway it gets better
because once you put crazy people in
charge of your Newsroom well crazy
things happen so they try to call an all
hands meeting to explain why people were
being fired the real reason of course
that no one wants to listen to this crap
but an n-power executive had to get out
there and try to speak slowly and tell
these people why they were fired and
people start screaming at him
so he called for civility
and then one employee said you need to
read this piece quote when civility is
used as a cudgel against people of color
that's NPR ladies and gentlemen on the
inside NPR by the way we told you the
outset is now officially State media and
honestly that tells you a lot about the
state
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight